[Música]
en la historia de la humanidad hubo tres
pequeñas palabras que dejaron pensativos
a poetas filósofos en el ágora Y oyentes
de oráculos
quién soy desde el Antiguo aforismo
griego inscrito en el templo de Apolo
conócete a ti mismo hasta el himno de la
banda de rock quién eres filósofos
psicólogos académicos científicos
artistas teólogos y políticos todos han
abordado el tema de la identidad
sus hipótesis son variopintas y no
existe consenso son todas personas
creativas e inteligentes Por qué es tan
difícil dar con la respuesta correcta
una traba sin duda reside en el complejo
concepto de la persistencia de la
identidad cuál es tu verdadero tú la
persona que eres hoy la de hace cinco
años la que serás dentro de 50 años y
cuándo soy
esta semana hoy ahora en este segundo
qué parte de ti es este yo eres tu
cuerpo físico tus pensamientos y
sentimientos tus acciones estas aguas
turbias de la lógica abstracta son
difíciles de Navegar y por eso a lo
mejor conviene usar para demostrar su
complejidad lo que usó el historiador
griego Plutarco la historia de un barco
cómo llegas a ser yo
la historia cuenta que teseo el mítico
rey fundador de Atenas mató sin ayuda de
nadie al malvado minotauro de Creta y
luego regresó a su casa en un barco para
honrar esta hazaña heroica Durante los
siguientes mil años los atenienses
mantuvieron su barco atracado en el
puerto y recrearon anualmente su viaje
cada vez que algo en el barco se dañaba
se sustituía por una pieza idéntica del
mismo material hasta que en algún
momento ya no quedó nada de las piezas
originales Plutarco enfatizó que la nave
de teseo era un ejemplo de la paradoja
filosófica sobre la persistencia de la
identidad
Cómo se puede sustituir cada parte de un
todo y sin embargo que este siga siendo
la misma cosa
imaginemos que hay dos buques la nave
que teseo atracó en Atenas el barco a y
el barco con el que mil años más tarde
navegaban los atenienses la nave B
nuestra pregunta es muy simple y es la
siguiente a es igual a b algunos dirán
que durante mil años no hubo más que una
nave la de teseo y debido a que los
cambios Se realizaron gradualmente nunca
en ningún momento Dejó de ser la nave
legendaria
aunque no tienen absolutamente ninguna
parte en común los dos barcos son
numéricamente idénticos quiere decir que
son lo mismo de modo que a es igual a b
sin embargo otros podrían argumentar que
teseo nunca puso un pie en la nave b y
su presencia en el barco es una
propiedad cualitativa esencial de la
nave de teseo no puede sobrevivir sin él
así aunque los dos barcos son
numéricamente idénticos no son
cualitativamente idénticos por lo tanto
a no es igual a b
Pero qué sucede cuando consideramos esta
variante Qué pasa si ya que cada pieza
de la nave original fue desechada
alguien recogió todo aquello y
reconstruyó toda la nave original
una vez terminada
existirían dos naves físicas la que
estaba atracada en Atenas y la que está
en el patio trasero de este individuo
cada uno podría reclamar el título de la
nave de teseo pero solo una podría ser
en realidad la nave genuina Así que cuál
es la respuesta y lo más importante que
tiene esto que ver contigo al igual que
la nave de teseo usted es un conjunto de
partes en constante cambio el cuerpo
físico la mente las emociones sus
circunstancias e incluso sus
peculiaridades están siempre cambiando
pero de una manera increíble y a veces
ilógica Mientras usted Sigue siendo el
mismo Esta es una de las razones por las
que la pregunta Quién soy es tan
compleja y para responderla Como tantas
otras grandes Mentes que lo intentaron
antes debe estar dispuesto a profundizar
en la paradoja filosófica O tal vez
podría responder soy un héroe legendario
que viaja en un barco poderoso en un
épico eso podría funcionar también
siga explorando las preguntas
fundamentales de nuestra existencia con
este video y descubra las teorías más
intrigantes de la filosofía sobre Por
qué amamos y no olvides suscribirse a
nuestro canal
[Música]